[Music]
this is the moment a part of the nanda
devi glacier
broke flooding the dhali ganga river
the force of the water broke two dams
inundating the river
and destroying everything in its path
the havoc was caught on mobile phone
footage by residents
as they witnessed the wall of water rock
and dust
[Music]
i was looking around and i couldn't see
anything but five minutes later i
witnessed something that looked like a
scene from a film
i've never seen anything like what i saw
at the rishi ganga power plant
about 50 to 100 people were running for
their lives but couldn't be saved
and they were engulfed by the river
many are reported dead but officials
fear over 150 workers
are missing from the two hydro power
plants at rishi ganga and holy
both the plants have been flooded and
heavily damaged
[Music]
20 workers trapped in an under
construction tunnel
have been rescued
teams from the military paramilitary and
other security forces
have been rushed into the area medical
teams
have been called into local hospitals
and put on standby
in a tweet prime minister narendra modi
said india stands with uttarakhand
and the nation prays for everyone's
safety there
thousands of people have now been
evacuated from their homes
authorities have alerted people living
downstream the alaknanda river
to move to safer places immediately
neville lazarus sky news india